because i got one for you
you know i was in new york one time and
it's late i'm walking in the street how
long give me some context how long ago
it's this might be like a couple years
ago so you're a grown man i'm a grown-up
if somebody yelled the n-word at you bro
i'mma come out and say honestly that
could have been me dude
back off my broccolini
get your life together
touch me bro i'm not touching you
dude ryan's head looks so weird with
those headphones on it yeah it does you
don't gotta hit so long why because i
got i got i got a long head yeah you
have oh you have a head like a rugby
ball i don't have a good head for hats
or headphones yeah i would just like
it's long yeah yeah it's like really i
got a long head in this long this way so
i actually take a much larger hat than
you would imagine yeah it doesn't look
like you would take a long hat i got a
long why do you think you're you are
seven of them yeah seven five eight uh
are you eight big hat whatever you take
i'm sure i take oh no no no oh yeah i
mean no i haven't no i might be able to
circumference like you have a small
right i'm like the monsters from uh
mario bros actually yeah you know the
guys with small hair you got a small
head i got it up here it's fat down here
so i wear seven and one fourth i can fit
a seven three eight stew my head goes
long
long like the comedy section
oh
your head it's just it's like a big
you have such good references for [ __ ]
how the [ __ ] do you remember these
things 91 i think i don't know i love
that movie
yeah your head's like uh yeah it's like
it's like you know the guy from masks
one time i'm so daring on mad tv you had
you had to pitch your own characters and
this was my idea for a character it's
[ __ ] i come into them and i go like
this i go um i have an idea for a
character later i just want my ears to
be a little higher
just right here that'd be funny i know
and they're like that's funny i go
what's the catch i go that's it i just
wanna don't bring anything yeah i just
want my ears to be a little house but a
human yeah and people can't figure out
what's wrong with me but they can't like
you know and i'm just the guy when you
leave they talk behind your back right
right you something funny yeah
yeah it would be great and then they
decided that it would be way too hard
for the makeup people oh come on i don't
know
but i always thought that would be a
funny sketch that was the main thing on
the character though you just had big
ears no my ears are just a little high
like they're just they're righteous but
a human face and you wouldn't know you'd
be like his ears are i think it's up
with that guy and they can't put their
finger on it i don't know what it is
well you know they do that with where
they'll they'll part your hair so
apparently
your hair can part this way when they
part some people's hair the other way
they look like [ __ ] it goes against
their face so people don't have a
positive reaction to you people go i
don't like that guy there's only one way
to find out though
unless your stylist knows what the
[ __ ] up part it the wrong way and i've
done that and i look like a [ __ ]
yeah when one even have enough no you're
up top
i look like a in this way i look like a
hitler sympathizer this way i look
forward but you don't have long enough
to go hitler no i keep it tight you know
i took tiger get his haircut last night
because they had school pictures today i
told the guy dude don't make it so tight
and high on the side because he hitlered
him dude he hit him yeah
did i ask for the hitler bro talk about
retiring a hairstyle and mustache style
for like ever you can't wear that dude
like name somebody
well michael jordan in the hands
commercial well i mean but that's just
cause his lip is weird yeah he has no
top up upper lip that's just bad makeup
but it wasn't but it wasn't this short
yeah yeah bring that [ __ ] up champ
michael jordan was the only guy said
you're right
[ __ ] it i'm bringing the greatest of all
time i'm bringing the ad off back i'm
black so nobody can call me a nazi they
both have that [ __ ] this energy and
is that a name that has been like
retired to hitler yeah well hold on they
don't put they don't well maybe is there
like a hit like your last name is hitler
like what do you do that's a hip hippie
that's a homie
oh you know what he messed up that's
just a bad yeah yeah he just shaved this
side [ __ ] up and then he's the guy
that comes because you know he still has
a little hair i think i think that's
doctor too i think that i think they did
that on purpose to make no
that he came out the hitler and
everybody's too scared to talk nobody
says [ __ ] no i'm like dude that looks
sick i might be the first person to ever
say this
like he's so untouched
you know it's like everyone else is too
cool he's so untouched did you see him
in that uh what what was the series he
did the the last the last dance yeah did
you see how bread his eyes were though
why was i so [ __ ] ready that's that's
a thing he probably smoking weed or like
he had too many cigars cigars can do
that to you but they're like a yellow
red though like i guess they they there
there were doctors and like scientists
saying how like his eyes are alarming
how yellow like look at that yeah
because that can be jaundice hepatitis
that can be a lot of things with your
liver that can be a problem with your
liver or you're a lizard person
underneath or you're
or you're an animal that'd be terrible
to find out there's that that he's not
real yeah that he was just like an alien
the whole time it would be heartbreaking
it'd be like oh man that makes sense and
then you start to go who else is a
lizard you know what i mean
barry sanders was a lizard uh you know
he's the only man who can cry without
covering his face look at that [ __ ] well
it looks like you got maced like yeah
looks like you got pepper spray it does
he's crowned over kobe there i think no
there's granddad's hall of fame speech
oh yeah he cries a lot now he's crying
yeah well he's always he and tom brady
you can make tom brady watch this all
you have to do is tom brady's go tell me
about your dad he'll go
there's certain triggers i think for
every man for me it's with my kids if
anything about like if it's mother and
son any kind of thing niagara falls is
that right yeah there's like a movie and
there's like a touching mother-son scene
i'm out every time i watch joe coyne
yeah no every time i watch uh joe coy
salute his mom and start to cry yeah
yeah i i get it every time do you mean
the sam adams commercial yes like i
wonder if like is that planned i mean
every time i see what is that uh what
does it say no because we shot the same
commercial none of it's planned they
don't know
was that commercial yeah it was for sam
adams bear i don't even know and i don't
know so it was me
theo uh i think ari and then joe coy and
the thing was is like you have to
someone that you toast to someone that
like kind of made your career whatever
oh i think because theo has no friends
he toasts it to the crowd which makes
sense joe rogan must be furious yeah
well
and then and then joe coy uh ari toasted
to red band i think yeah and then uh i
toasted to brian oh but he didn't know
and then joe coy toasted his mom but
they like they didn't know what they're
signed up for right i was like hey just
come just come here we're shooting here
it's pretty cool yeah it's cool oh
that's nice yeah how come i didn't see
those other ones i only remember the joe
coy one
this one is very emotional man
he loves his mom oh you know what i'm
proud of you see you started this
you're the reason why i've been able to
do this thank you for everything you've
sacrificed
don't need these this is for you oh god
i love you
yeah you're saying father
i mean
this is me this is me right yeah i
you know he's dating chelsea handler now
they confirmed it it's not true i didn't
mean to ruin the moment but what yeah
confirmed can we talk about this talk
about a couple they never see getting
together they know each other so well
because i'm not going to show the show
forever yeah he should actually toast
her
[Laughter]
you know i used to i used to i used to
do that joe a lot oh i know remember
back in the day and i decided one day i
was like it was you joking yeah i'm
friends with you he did it yeah i mean
whoever did it
they they launched into like a career
that you just go how did this happen it
was like the tonight show yeah man it
was crazy well i i see i was always
friends with chelsea
yeah i know i was always friends with
chelsea i loved her and i did the pilot
of that i did the the not even the i did
sort of the test pilot is the operative
word
and then and then i started doing it a
lot and i watched myself and i saw it
was all gossip and it was going bad on
celebrities and i just decided i was
like i don't want to do this anymore it
doesn't make me feel good i didn't feel
funny and i didn't feel good and even
chelsea one time the last time i did she
goes you seem kind of reserved you know
i just don't like roasting people when
they can't defend themselves especially
sand mean things so i just stopped doing
it that was a bad career choice but yeah
it probably was it definitely was like
brian dunkelman from uh american idol
yeah he's the other host yeah i don't
like this the show's lame and ryan
seacrest like cool i'll take it from
here
now like 30 million dollars a year later
yeah
duncan is in like a two-bedroom condo in
reseda i've made i've made a lot of
those decisions no he's part of the
think boy network now he's on podcast
buzz buzz fights fights ufc 266 is here
and draftking sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the ufc has
quite the heavyweight offer for you guys
this weekend with a special odds boost
for all the viewers and listeners the
king of the sting for fighters this week
i picked three
bad man pajamas it's a parlay all three
have to win in order for you to get your
money and i picked these three because
it's gonna be fun now two of them are
dogs all right two of them are dogs and
one's a heavy favorite but two of them
are dogs that i think we're all gonna be
rooting for i'm talking about curtis
blades the favorite all right over rose
and strook nick diaz fan favorite who
bets against nick diaz [ __ ] and then
you got brian ortega who's fighting in
the main event against volkanovsky so
you gotta have curtis blades nick diaz
and brian ortega all win and we're all
gonna make bank bro
just head to the app right now find the
brennan shops picks under the odds boost
tab doesn't matter if you're new or an
existing customer bet on it get your
boosted odds and ride along with your
thick friend right here all new users
download the top-rated draftking
sportsbook app right now use the promo
code k-a-t-s when you sign up bet on my
parlay of fighters to win saturday night
for ufc 266 nick diaz brian ortega and
curtis blades and take advantage of my
special odds boost that's promo code
kats only at draftking sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of the
ufc
must be 21 and older new jersey
pennsylvania indiana michigan virginia
only restrictions apply see
draftkings.com sportsbook for details
gambling problem okay call winning
hundred gambler or in virginia eight
eight eight five three two thirty five
hundred we all got that family member
maybe your step mom maybe maybe it's one
of your kids always be farting you
always worry about their guts they got
gut issues all the time man turns out
everything you think you know about
probiotics may be wrong man i know it's
wrong man all right good news seeds
daily symbiotic is the real deal looking
for a way to ease that bloating you're
not alone man in fact two out of three
americanos live with digestive
discomfort including bloating prolonged
fullness also doo-doo issues all right
seed is working to change all that many
pro probiotics can't survive the trip to
your gut good news seeds daily symbiotic
can and does all right not all
probiotics are created equal just
because it says oh bro backs in this ooh
good no this is the real deal holy field
all right what's in the daily symbolic
good question chin thanks for asking
broad spectrum two in one probiotic
prebiotic all right systematic benefits
beyond the gut all right what does the
daily symbiotic do for you
you'd never ask man supports benefits in
and beyond the gut all right many see
improvements in digestion within 24 to
48 hours which can include doodoo
movements all right and ease bloating so
start a new healthy habit today visit
seed.com kats use the code cats to
redeem to 20 off your first month of
seeds daily symbiotic that's seeds.com
kats and youth code cats
is it mr theo von harris hey guys can
you hear me
rat king stink house sting this zoo
house
rack king in the house here we go rat
king in the house
[Laughter]
yeah we got the senior citizens section
in here with us today hey hey man what's
up man we're trying to give back to the
old folks you know looking like he's 31.
oh i'm just saying we got that celiac
section here
i know we act like stevie's not 50. yeah
aren't you in your 40s
nah baby i'm 39 baby
someone asked me at one of my shows how
old theo is i'm like he might be 24 it
might be 54. we have he doesn't know
dude i'm in middle school baby let's go
that's right i was riding my bike
tonight and this guy kept going uh i'm
downstairs i'm downstairs he kept going
buzz buzz i'm downstairs i'm like what
the [ __ ] is this guy talking about and
he pulls up he goes i'm downstairs baby
but he i get it because theo on his
instagram post a video going i'm
upstairs when he caught the fish oh this
guy was on a little motorcycle that's
really loaded oh yeah so we kept going
on downstairs theo i had no idea you
were such an outdoorsman oh lowriders
yeah man well a lot of it i'm still
learning man i just got a knife the
other day a pretty decent knife good a
sheath knife was it a sheath knife or
just a a folding blade
it's more of an indoor knife i'd say
dinner and maybe a lit you know yeah
yeah heavy dessert oh like an outback
stuff was it a fixed blade knife was it
a fixed blade would you fold it into the
handle butterfly knife
no he got a cake knife you know what i
mean like yeah
yeah that's more you know coffee cake
i would say heavy dessert i would say it
marzipan and up
see you can stab and spread
oh you could now yeah if you want to
make a freaking damn creme brulee out of
a burglar you could do that with it
okay you still out there killing fish
still what are you doing dog
no what am i doing a buddy of mine took
me to this breath work thing but it was
a damn uh
lamaze we ended up at a damn lamaze
class trying to do uh you know we're
trying to do like a breathing seminar
have you guys ever done that brian
hoff that wim hof [ __ ]
yeah this was more like uh yeah yeah i
did that they do it in cold water i did
that but then and then i listened to
these four men who dedicated their lives
to meditation right like
they're called contemplative athletes
right
never mind that the two of them teach
mindfulness and buddhism in a big
university anyway long story short
they've been doing it for 30 years each
you know and they all they all they were
all like and here's the problem it's
like what's the problem i said the
minute you stop meditating you go back
to real life and all the [ __ ] that you
think you're gonna be able to
it doesn't really it doesn't necessarily
make you zen all the time you still
[ __ ] up three weeks of
hard work and therapy i'm sorry buddy
but it's all you but you're saying this
it sounds like a distraction
what did you get hey theo what did you
get from the breath class
oh man i had some real breakthroughs man
uh
it's good there's this girl named blair
sochi that teaches it she's a young
comedian
uh
and she teaches it over the thing your
arms get all locked up like a little
lobster yeah and uh lobster all your
feelings come out dude i mean you'll
damn
you start crying you start crying
dude you'll have a twin sister you never
met climb out of your throat but i got
some intense [ __ ] happening
i worked with uh breathing guys i got
these uh navy seal guys yeah like they
teach the navy seals that when i was
fighting i got it supposed to help you
like get in the zone combat breathing or
something [ __ ] is the beast does it help
yeah i still do it to this day when i
get yeah before i go on stage it helps
yeah i've also seen you have fritos
before you go on stage so i think you're
obviously using a couple different
tactics fritos are good whiskey do a
little whiskey before he wants to taste
whisky
and breathing yeah oh no he's blind no
there's a fly
[ __ ]
sorry man
put your knife out like a man frog
no there's a ah
wasp
no no smaller than that i'm not fly net
mosquito yeah i don't want to use a
racial slur net
[Laughter]
yeah there's a nat in here dude you know
what i'm talking about dear i want to
know what you spend the bulk of your day
thinking about
i would probably say
that's a good question dude usually
it used to be dinner
okay and then it's gotten out of hand
since then that was probably 2008 and
since then shit's kind of spiraled out
of control
[Laughter]
remember when you thought about dinner
you were like dude what's gonna happen
what are we gonna have what are we gonna
drink with it
how's it gonna end when i'm gonna do my
last bite eat fast eat slow who am i
going to look at you got real problems
yeah and then they start just bulking up
the freaking
you know things get busier you got this
you got that dude and now you barely
even feel like eating and it's just the
food could have poison in it biden could
be poison and all this [ __ ] yes
okay so let me ask you this if i do you
think your life would change and what
would you do with 20 million dollars
because you got a lot of money now
i do not have a lot of money now all
right i think there's a myth all right i
give you let's let's put it this way
i give you a hundred million dollars
meaning you're set you don't have to
worry in the bank
you don't have to work you have to work
for money at all what happens to you in
that week in that year we stopped the
week is get the week gets dicey the week
gets
i would say celebration celebration i
would take a bag full of purity tests
down to
colombia yeah okay yup yup
good stuff clean coke i call that clean
blow
oh dude yeah
no freak oh god bless
the good stuff i think phil i think theo
will be like there'll be like a 30 for
30 how he lost 100 million yeah going
bro you know what i mean
yeah then he's like 30 for theo yeah
he's got like he had to open a board
you know yeah thirty for thea thirty for
theo yeah thirty ends with him and him
and kid rock on jet skis
dude they should have a thirsty
they should have thirsty for thirsty and
it's just half these thoughts out there
in l.a
this week for
actually like that show that sounds like
thirsty for thirsty's lit you got some
of the [ __ ] only fan models on there
oh yeah how much they make how they put
it all together damn that's a good idea
wow it would be pretty crazy but i don't
know you know what i would do i think i
would want to take on i think honestly i
might go back to school man i think i'd
go back to school for like a writing
school or i would enlist in the military
i think i would do something right
where i could just take on it yeah those
days if i have a hundred million dollars
i'm not joining the military because
like day one when they're like give me
20. i'm out thank you 100 million who
are you yelling at 20 i'm the [ __ ] out
of here
so you give them 20 bucks at that point
baby
you go to school though and study
writing school you could do that you
could do that military you're too old
military you're too old but you don't
need to have a hundred million dollars
for you to go to school you could do
that right now they got online
universities oh yeah nicki minaj uh was
taking classes on at harvard online
you have to think about sentences before
you say them you can't just be saying
you could do it though man you both got
an ass nba players do that too yes you
know they still don't like i got a
nba player that one dude has done it i
don't know there's plenty of guys i
think i think shaq finished school
online whatever he did i think
nba is a part-time job they work for six
months they can go to school
uh many many athletes have done it i i
don't know all of them off the top of my
head but and many of them did they do it
j.r smith just did it didn't he just go
back i'm just oh he did it to to join
the golf team though too but he's on the
golf yeah
like if you make um you know you go to
like you're gonna make 20 million
whatever the money you're gonna maintain
you're gonna make this guaranteed money
it don't mean that you don't have to go
to school that's a myth they think like
you go to school you when you work you
could never go to school again no they
just like you know
i'd be cool i'm with deal on that make
hundred mill go back i would probably
just call my degree i would use my
college degree i think yeah would you
live would you live in nashville or los
angeles where would you live well
i keep the same path back and forth it's
more i like here it's definitely more
peaceful here it's easy like this this
past weekend i drove to my shows like
shout out dude it was nice i could sleep
in the van if i got tired i wasn't like
on a plane where you can't really sleep
and you're yeah just seeing if people
are fighting behind you you just want to
you're just on the side of a road
sleeping sleep you're trying to get
kills i was going to say trying to get
me not napping while maniac stopping
kidding me that's how people died they
just drive by
orthotic we find it orthotic in the
woods too dude right by the interstate
what's an orthotic
appendage you know what i'm saying form
less orthopedic right or
orthotic methodic orthotic or thought
okay but i would use my degree man i'm
an urban planner man and uh i never you
have gotten to put my degree to use and
i would probably use that honestly if i
had unlimited money all right
theo threw out the first pitch at the
cardinals game how'd you throw recently
yeah
two days ago did you for the saint louis
cardinals
can i say louis cardinals man did you
did well do you know a little outside
but did you practice still
i did i stopped and practiced a couple
different places and i thought it was
good man were you able to get up from
the mound or did they scoot you closer
like you're [ __ ] from the women's
tees dude from the freaking menstrual
mound no way dude i did from the male
area full mound or nolan ryan i'm sorry
or trans there's area
he said i did for them at kevin bay's
place i i i was pitching from a real
mountain it's a long way let me practice
that [ __ ] got that loot out brim piece
on son let's go
there we go
the jersey's fire
look at this
do i go out there
they said rocky yeah that's awesome
they're rad kings
[Music]
[Music]
bro if you wanted to go viral he should
have [ __ ] threw it the other way man
like 50 cent
i thought about it i watched a lot of
mark wahlberg has one of the worst
pitches ever dr fauci the guy who
is leading what something is he also has
that dude can't some of those not dude
um who else is she through a ball yeah
how bad does voucher want to be famous
yeah what do you mean how bad he's
famous well that's that's his goal yeah
no but i mean he's already famous yeah
he got famous to pandemic look at him
he's wearing a mask even in the field
he's wearing a mask well yeah he kind of
has well yeah i guess he has this thing
but that's his look that's like me
wearing a thick boy shirt yeah there is
he look at it he's 80 something he's
just a shape dog yeah he's got a bad
he's got a bad uh shoulder boom
you know he should have went like this i
just got my shot so
johnson and johnson my [ __ ] shoulder
he's 80 years older and he still runs
every day he's in some shape
well he's a doctor uh 50 cent was
probably the worst someone else did a
real [ __ ] he just threw it over to the
[ __ ] what's kind of tough because so
far away
well
feel the best one i've seen i was
celebrity yeah that was good light on
celebrity but still
judd abbatel shut up oh my god let me
see that this is the biggest soy boy
throw in the world
shout out to stevia stevie that's one of
stevie's [ __ ]
yeah
yeah
let me see let's see
man he is he is not was it like his
comedy special
time stamp
[Laughter]
make sure we play it twice please
should we play it twice the fact that
they let that guy get up is unbelievable
i have not look at his
in this jersey and those shorts man i
want to throw a ball right now
oh my god
yeah what was that little flick like ha
ha
it's not a shot put what the [ __ ] are
you doing ah
dude dude he threw that thing away like
a good joke
[Laughter]
so embarrassing
uh they catch me like all right well you
do great wallberg had a bad one wahlberg
had i didn't know that yeah wahlberg's
athletic too
you really did your research before you
went out there i think people don't
realize like you got to practice yeah
you throw it a few times these are
professional athletes even though like
you look at baseball and you go this
doesn't look like a a real thing like
something that takes athleticism but
it's pretty pretty if you haven't thrown
but you know i kind of grew up throwing
a baseball a lot you know so you can
kind of yeah so did i but when's the
last time you threw first yeah not now
yeah because you got to practice you do
you practice you went to the mound and
that's why you know he threw them the
first time i did it at kevin's i was
like damn this is way harder yeah i hit
the ground and the mounds like up like
this yeah perch a little bit i hit the
ground i was like oh [ __ ] i'm upstairs
that's what it is when you film that
baseball
was that no one ryan no how dare you
yeah it was no it's not
who was that oh that was that was 50
cents
let me see
is so bad
no ryan who's that
texas
oh okay yeah let's sped through those i
tried to find mark wahlberg oh do we
here we'll watch 50s yeah 50s is tough
man we expected 50. this is like
chappelle lacy playing basketball
i assumed he was good and then he's the
worst you've ever seen why'd you assume
that yeah you know
you know
hey
you know
who else had a rough one i can't there
was some other rough ones it's a tough i
think maybe the nerves it was nice out
there the interesting thing was just how
beautiful the uh field is man there's
like a guy with a damn manscaped thing
out there just manscaping the edge of
the deal 4.0 just landscaping the side
of it
yeah uh sometimes oh okay i don't know
but it was it was impressive that's why
i'm so clean down there
um what's been going on brian i haven't
seen you in a while i miss you buddy
thanks for that message he sent me the
nice semester he goes hey man i met this
girl who just loves you man thinks
you're great just want to let you know
people out there love you my biggest
compliment about you brian honestly is
you're one of the few people
very few handful not even a full handful
of comic comedic persons that i don't
mind is still on off stage
oh yeah he's always you know what i'm
saying but i'm saying i've seen his
actions
it's not an annoying no no it's like
it's also brian it's you're right
exactly but you can go to dinner with
them guys
i'll go
turn brian on yeah i'm good for the
night yeah you're good you know but
that's all
brian you take it from here well that's
because i got you as an audience like if
i have my friends there my my goal is to
crack my friends up so now i'm just
going to be a [ __ ] even if you don't
know him yeah and if you if i'm bored
i'm going to do something to get on
board right quick so that's a lot of
times we would be out and i just be like
if we were certain people like that one
girl i made you left so hard she was
like my dog
my dog has a bad heart and i was just
like
dog's got a bum ticker
and could die at any time and i just
kept being sensitive
but if i have that if i have somebody
who's going to be laughing like rogan
you're trying to make some make your
friends laugh as opposed to like a lot
of comics are trying to be the funniest
person in the room there's a difference
oh yeah yeah there's a difference no i'm
trying to make it it's organic yeah i'm
saying he don't have to try to it's very
few i i thank you i appreciate that
that's very nice of that compliment i
appreciate that like with rogan when we
would hunt we'd both be miserable and i
get [ __ ] bored sitting around waiting
for a [ __ ] turkey to show up and i
start getting mad because it's my life
and i'm sitting there with a [ __ ]
mask with leaves on it because turkeys
get scared and that's it's called
wasting time it's wasting time and then
rich people and then don't don't do this
to me don't go like this don't go shh we
can't make any noise if you do that now
i gotta scream i'm [ __ ] gay
which is what i did i think i think
there's four men dressed up like turkeys
come out then
literally i think rogue is rogan's
missing you'll see 266 so he's hunting
right yeah yeah no way which one is that
is that uh chandler uh no it's uh nick
diaz robbie lawler uh brian ortega
volcanowskis this saturday
what if we find out secretly like rogan
is like
one of some secret society where they
hunt human beings
oh
how does rogan die do you think man if
you guys had to forecast it i don't
think he dies i think he meshes with
machines yeah
yeah like robocop yeah he's all about
technology he's already taken but he
wouldn't be a robocop he'd still be
doing podcasts yeah you know robo
podcast he he's already taken all those
like like all that stuff that david
sinclair yeah how liberal dude what if
one of his arms turns into a freaking uh
so you can just do it from wherever he
wants
yeah
he likes he likes technology he's all
about even if it's new science he's like
bring it my way but that's the you i
always read about these things that this
is they're saying that's the next phase
that next evolution of humanity is going
to be
uh cybernetics and i thought it was
downloading your consciousness no that's
that's way in the future
right right now right now it's meshing
with like synthetic biology would you
want that though you brought that up can
we ask can i ask everybody download your
consciousness do you do you want to like
you know you're in a car accident and
then you wake up and you're in a machine
no
man no part of being human is knowing
her limited it would hurt if you had to
read all your consciousness at one point
and you read it printed out it would be
i feel like it would be so painful to
you or it might be helpful you might
like
see like all these patterns of like
weird stuff or or troubled spots and
just be able to just well if it's but if
it's some kind of like virtual world if
it was if it was set up that like how
would you envision it you know like
you're in like you know
grantham you could be in grand theft
auto game yeah
i mean part of it's like part of like
the beauty of
life is there's a clock on [ __ ] like
you're limited man yeah because imagine
like your wife dies or something yeah
and then like now she's in the machine
so now i can't get
other chicks because she's like she's
talking [ __ ] she's still where are you
going
yeah it's like let me turn this [ __ ]
off
yeah i'll just turn off like shut up
[ __ ]
i mean you know what i mean like you
gotta get turned off it's not going to
be like that like what are you talking
about it is time is a [ __ ] like
i'm looking at this robbie lawler nick
diaz thing and i love those both those
guys but time is time and time
even with the the strongest and the
brightest and the best will well for
athletes though yeah it's different
shelf life
well i don't like the fact that if
people are living longer
but like
at
80
like do you want to live to 150 like
like dr fauci right now is 80. you're
still running and stuff but yeah the man
can't throw a ball you know what i'm
saying like yeah
if he gets to 120 like what is that
existence it depends on what you're
trying to do but what's that existence
though yeah if you've got a great book
inside you you got a great one hour
inside of you maybe maybe right if the
business obviously was still doing the
goddamn thing yeah i know but i mean
weird references yeah but it's true if
if
if the job is self-expression like don
rickles was still [ __ ] murdering
crowds
at right before he died like a minute
before he died
right so
you know it depends on what you it
depends on what's keeping you alive
we're talking about people who are like
80 90 and what i'm saying is you're
already like that what existence that is
yeah imagine with now people are
starting to live longer but they're not
we're not staying younger longer right
no they're just we're just prolonging
we're just prolonging your life so i'm
saying like so you know
i think folks home with people who are
130 years old
i think i think it's different when you
have kids eric you're like i want to be
as i go hey that's why dude i'm working
on health because that's my next goal
that's that's a really good point
watching watching your kids grow you got
to get healthy dog you don't need to get
a little thicker rhett that's what i
think that gum dog leaned down a little
bit i like that
i have a thicker rat
thicker nicotine
thicker wisdom
[Laughter]
you're not you're not you're not
depression yeah yeah
depression uh feelings therapy funny
steel is a perfect example of like where
people think like they look at you from
the outside and think like like you
don't think anybody can have a problem
if they have something or they're doing
something that you
admire
you know it's just weird how the world
works like yeah because they see theo on
the inside you're always having a good
time
or whoever whoever and then you're like
oh they they're set man i know and then
you see the story about that they can't
go well yeah actually i'm chronically
depressed and um this is that and then
like the regular person's like what yeah
i can put my pants on maybe that should
be the show is like the day in the life
of like a depressed person that you
think has a great life oh i don't want
to watch that but it would be everywhere
you're already living that with theo
you know what i mean theo how's your
how's your mental state been you made me
bipolar
i think it's it's hit or miss dude i've
been battling i think i have some kind
of like a syndrome or something i don't
know what it is so i'm fighting that but
what's the scene
just like chronic fatigue man i don't
know what it is i'm checking out like
lyme's disease i'm checking out all
kinds of stuff man
i'll say this about theo though whatever
mental things are going on with him he
does he [ __ ] fights man oh he fights
oh he fights yeah that's the thing that
people need to see has a fighter's heart
man i'll give you
you know yeah i'm saying like this is it
i mean i like
if you look at theo's podcast now hold
on and then when it started at the uh
yeah the breath
me no i'm not
you look a little out of breath right
now and i'm no i'm not a breath of the
emotional talk about theo oh i'm sorry
okay i thought it was the nicotine
you're a sociopath i get worried you
can't reach human i didn't mean that i i
i saw you go like this i was like just
always digging
i got worried i was like are you fat out
of breath
i just i know he's doing that nicotine i
was like i don't like this [ __ ] you were
like
okay well thanks b man i appreciate you
man look i'm inspired by you bro you're
a fighter man you know i think you never
give up
uh brandon or brendan um
it is a [ __ ] game though
brendan anything any one of those names
is so easy to like brendan brandon it's
like pick one bro yours is eric with a k
oh it's still eric
i'm going to spell it
you know what i mean it's like but
there's more famous brendan's than our
brand name another favorite brendan
fraser brendan shanahan brandon frazier
you really wanna he came back he's out
of shape but he's back
encino man
who's with me you name two [ __ ]
two name name of famous brandon brandon
lee
bruce lee's son
god we're reaching well i i hate greg
and craig oh yeah yeah drive me up a
[ __ ] wall or brett and brent [ __ ] a
banner i met a kid named banner the
other day and i was like whoa
banner yeah banner's [ __ ] at home
like bruce banner he said he was named
after bruce band
that's [ __ ] oh man oh my god let's
get to the show what do you got nick
eric had a story i think he wanted to
bring for us uh you had a story about
and this is great because it's these
three
this is about like what's your most
cowardly moment like my [ __ ] out moment
because i got one for you
you know i was in new york one time and
it's late i'm walking in the street how
long give me some context how long ago
it's this might be like a couple years
ago grown i'm a grown-up someone if
somebody yelled the n-word at you bro
i'm gonna come out and say honestly that
could have been me dude
yeah but theo would just be like eric
and then drop the hand what up
you ain't hiding
so i'm walking down the street and then
there's like a couple that's like three
or four paces ahead of me they're
walking i got my phone out and then a
dude walks behind me and bumps me okay
oh yeah like he bumps me man i go whoa
and then he goes over to the couple
and he starts attacking them oh damn
like he starts swinging on the girl tell
me you ran wait wait wait he starts
swinging on the girl he's spitting on
her and then other dude is like this
he's the dude is like hey stop it get
back you know what he's like going crazy
dude that straight up was like let me
walk across
[Laughter]
this is where i exit left i said dude i
straight up walked across the street i
was like i didn't want to deal with what
did the guy look like was the guy
homeless or had his [ __ ] together no he
didn't have his [ __ ] together but but he
was a he was a big dude yeah okay he was
just a big and he had like a big jacket
on he was grizzly and i was like this
guy what's gonna happen right now yeah
and i just like i felt terrible
like i honestly felt but you didn't have
the tools to do anything dude i started
they did not that i even had the tools
now i did start boxing after that but i
don't mean like what the guy's gonna be
hold your hands up for me one two
but you know i just was like i'm across
the street and then and the scene keeps
playing out though because the guy's
like get off us you know and then the
guy starts leaving and the guy won't let
it go the other guy's like
somebody got up on ice and then i and
and the whole scene's kind of following
me and i'm like i'm trying to get away
from this [ __ ] somebody help them yeah
yeah yeah
but then i thought to myself i can't
even do that because i'm thinking to
myself like damn dude somebody could
have filmed that felt like a [ __ ] i did
i feel like somebody could be filming
like is that montana's running yeah
that's gonna hurt ticket sales there
see i'm i'm just saying i had that
moment and my thought first thought was
i'm a [ __ ] just no the first thought
was like this guy came this guy he is he
gonna kill them he ain't gonna kill
three of us you know what i mean and
then but then later i was like oh man i
should have helped yeah but i don't
think that's countless like for so for
me in that situation
i don't know what i would do i'm just
going to tell you this
every minute of my life since i was born
has been getting ready for that moment
i'm literally i'm so far ahead of that
dude like if i can't if i clock that um
so so in your head he starts going down
and that's because i'm afraid
yeah that's but that's also because i'm
afraid i'm so afraid that i have to be
ready for that [ __ ] so it depends on how
ready you are well you know the thing to
the thing too for me
i'm a big guy
so there's this assumption you're a big
guy so it's like you could fight and
stuff and i'm like no bro like it's like
yeah
i i've been in four fights my entire
life you know what i mean and one of
them was like i hit a girl in the sixth
grade you know what i'm saying
that was when i learned not to do that
ever again
she was a [ __ ] dude she was she was
never behind then wait listen she was a
bully right oh yeah she was being a
bully and i was like i punched her like
like in like right you know and then all
of a sudden she turned into a girl like
this she oh
and i was like oh [ __ ] what's that bully
energy and everybody was like oh man i
was like wait what's up eric everybody
just hated her
what happened guys and then i was like i
learned a lesson you know i learned a
lesson right there you know what i mean
yeah and then the only other time i
punched somebody is this guy was
bullying me on the bus in like the fifth
grade and i went home and told my mom i
was like just
you know my mom said tomorrow
punch him in the face good for your mom
that's what my mom said yeah punch him
in the face and at that time you're
afraid of your parents yeah so the only
thing i'm afraid of is my mom being mad
at me i'm punching i'm punching this
[ __ ] in the face mama said so i
was waiting for it too i was like come
on bully me [ __ ]
he did it i punched him in the face i
got suspended for a week but he never
worked it again worth never messed with
[ __ ] worth it never again that's what
your mom wanted you know and then she
drove me to school every day for a week
and stopped in front of the bus so so i
could get out of the car like right
whenever the bus was coming out and i
was like okay but like again that wasn't
really like a fight fight you're always
afraid no matter what yeah dude even if
you're tough i just uh last story okay
i'm i'm getting out i'm i'm pulling into
a 7-eleven in my car and a big bald head
skinhead looking dude with tattoos all
over his face he must have been like 6'4
i almost hit him that wasn't me and he
looked at me like oh man it was like he
was going to say the m word you know
what i mean like he was like like
so he said it internally he did it oh
yeah he did i parked i walked into the
7-eleven right and he was there in line
and he was looking at me y'all he was
giving me the light you know and so we
locked eyes
and i was like
oh [ __ ] i can't look away now you know
what i mean what you did i didn't oh
really i honestly didn't look away i
figured i gave him my best because i
used to be i used to work with kids so i
got like a like a a dean of students
look i can give yeah you know yeah
that's like but i mean i gave him the
look and then i'm waiting i'm getting
closer and he looks away
like he looks away and then i look i
went this way and i went like this oh my
god
i just thought what about you you ever
have i you know
uh in regards to that stuff like people
getting fighting the streets or like
that lady that i saw in the accident i i
just any moment you just like you had a
cowardly moment the cowardly moment i
have not that the stuff on the fighting
and started podcasting yeah yeah look
dude when i'm on the streets like it's
on yeah like i have this thing in me
where it's almost uh you've got a
problem you go where i want to help you
i'm like superman and my girl [ __ ]
hates it
also probably why she's married to me
but she [ __ ] hates it like i see like
like there's something like that going
on i'm gonna get involved yeah like to
the fullest yeah that's why i thought
about it i thought of you that's why i
brought this up because i thought i bet
you brendan would have liked you know
yep it had been on you had to move but
you're also ready you know what i mean
yeah i spent years training so yeah yeah
yeah so i feel like it's my duty yes all
right i'm the one out of every like
regular civilian i'm the one who could
[ __ ] this guy oh yeah i have to do it
especially yeah you know what you're so
right because then somebody films that
and they're like yeah what's the ufc
fighter doing nothing yeah that sucks
yeah but that's a lot of pressure but i
i think as far as [ __ ] outdoor my my
last fight when i retired with uh when i
fought travis brown he's this huge dude
i was in the back i looked at my coach
i'm like i don't want to do this i'm
terrified i do not want i don't want to
go out there man but that's not and they
were like dude
that's fine whatever happens out there
is on youtube he transforms i have to
walk like you have to make the walk
can't stay back here i'm like i don't
want to go i do not want to go they're
like dude dana's paying you eleven
thousand dollars get the [ __ ] out there
and you gotta split that six ways yeah
and my coaches right now we're taking 50
of that
that's that's if you're not going to be
scared fighting travis brown no but
that one was different that one was
different i didn't want to go out there
because i was scared i've always made
them also that was the one time i looked
at my coaches like hey this is the last
time i'm [ __ ] maybe because maybe
because you had options maybe you
started yeah
i'm going to say i was going to say also
also because you have
a healthy respect for what's happening
correct like that's a completely
different thing like i don't even count
that as like a cowardly moment it kind
of is though no no but i'm saying like
but it felt cowardly is what he's saying
it felt cowardly
i get you like like like and when the
ref stopped the fight and i like popped
i was like what i'm like
thank god yeah can i get in the
background gotta keep just going yeah
man you [ __ ] me man and i am about my
thank god
but i was like tipping over chairs and
[ __ ] to act like nobody wins in a fight
so i saw like i made some comment last
week about like look i'm not a fighter
but you know but i know that i i'm going
to go i'm going to do whatever i can you
know
whatever it is i'm a scratch i'm going
to kick you in the balls i'm doing
whatever i can that's what i always
meant by that last thing i'm not saying
because what i'm saying is there's no
winner in a fight no no one wins in a
fight nope there's someone who gets hurt
more but every flight you've ever had
you were hurt right unless unless you
got tired unless you got pepper spray
that's all you fight just walk away theo
you got any [ __ ] out moments man oh
yeah bubba
i'll tell you one so i was in
i was in i think germany or somewhere
else
and
i was with my ex-girlfriend beautiful
girl i don't remember her name at the
moment but fine as hell
and pretty cool pretty nice actually
kind of looked like her dad a little bit
but also
great girl
anyway um he did not describe anything i
want to see
we were
biking on one of those bike tours in a
foreign country where it's like you know
you get on the blue bike and you all go
to the different things and everything
and
her bike was like sticking into some
like like bike path we'd pulled over and
the guy was like telling us about some
you know ancient jewelry or something
and
this some guy was speeding through the
bike path and like hit the back of her
tire kind of on purpose like he was like
kind of had this this like [ __ ] these
tourists type of energy
and and then like he kind of looked at
me and then he just pedaled off and she
kind of looked at me like are you gonna
do something and it just like i did i
just like still have dreams where i like
pedal after this dude i could have taken
the dude at least at least i could have
attacked him and like beat him with a
bike i don't know if i could have beat
him up something
did you play i didn't do anything
i just got nervous i don't know what
happened i just
i don't know if i cared about her enough
to do any i don't know what happened
that yeah that could be a sign you just
did something yeah i mean there are
women that they're not you can be on a
date and it's not worth getting your ass
kicked for i had that i had that with a
guy i was like i don't like this girl
and i'm not getting i'm not fighting
this dude but i know i would have told
the guy that i wish i would have at
least tracked the guy down and said look
i
i could do something but if i cared more
i would do something yeah that's fair he
would have respected that and like yeah
cool man that's why yeah he was like is
that oh that [ __ ] just hurts me dude
what's this nick uh this guy's got his
own story about how he bitched out oh
what's up this is shane
from newport michigan great audience
what's up i got a bitched out for you
guys so my wife decides to go to bed
early well when i was at work we work
midnights so the bars are usually closed
by the time we get off work
and the liquor stores so we never get a
chance to celebrate at a bar during any
time of week that we're working
we get sent home early we decided to go
to the bar
while i'm at the bar my wife wakes up i
told her hey we're going to go to the
bar i know you're sleeping i'll be home
a little bit i love you whatever
she came up there with a baby in her arm
in my face and i'm just standing there
all my co-workers are just looking at me
and the next day they was like oh man
you in the doghouse son
ain't right man gang gang buzz buzz
so did she like pull so do you not
defend yourself and just jumped in the
car with your wife how do you [ __ ] out
i think that's it he he jumped in the
car was like i see fellas tomorrow yeah
yeah that's all right though i i have
there has to be trust issues though i do
if he just went to a bar with his
co-workers after work and she pulls up
and wakes the baby up pulls up in her
[ __ ]
dodge neon like what the [ __ ] are you
doing like
and why the baby got having one [ __ ]
down
the baby i get woken up you know how
hard it you know and to put that kid
back and sleep something that's
expensive baby's like all right
all right dad all right dad that was she
was testing him but then that's kind of
like weighing it like harmony in the
home [ __ ] these guys i work with i i'll
tell you one [ __ ] that move but what
else you can do disrespect your wife
shut up [ __ ] yeah get in the [ __ ]
car
we're waiting till barclay i get in the
car it depends on your worth that that
mustache is is amazing fantastic that's
my verse hitler my one [ __ ] that guy's
that's guy i gotta talk about him for a
sec i've never that mustache that that's
the reverse hitler that is the craziest
though
yeah that's a young feeling his hair his
mustache matches his eyebrows you mean
like 36 year old theo
what do you mean by young theory yeah
his eyebrows and mustache are exactly
the same wow that's a woman that did the
man filter that's what i think because
his neck and shoulders are very very
very what's he say thank you thank you
he's got his own [ __ ] that's story
my name is mason i'm from pensacola
florida this is the worst i've ever
bitched out great here so
it's actually beautiful on a first date
with this girl
it was actually the first date i had
ever been on
oh yeah yeah because that's
hard already i'm hoping i was really
into her i could tell she was into me
end of the night we're sitting in my car
we're talking
yes
looking at each other you know
and
i knew i was supposed to kiss her i just
couldn't do it not with that much i
leaned in towards her couldn't kiss her
no
long story short i asked how are mom's
doing and then later she asked me are
you sure you're not gay
we know it went well ah yes well we were
asking the same question
he's kind of camera if he just panned
the camera to his husband right there
yeah
yeah
just roll over just something yeah
but who wins now teresa
[Laughter]
that is the toughest dude when you know
that's the one of the biggest ones i
think when you know you're supposed to
make a move on a woman this hot girl bra
named noel i grew up with this girl
named noel bro
and she has this
right here
she had beautiful brush she was 100
beautiful dude you could bro if she even
if you couldn't even see her she was
fine as [ __ ] even if she was in a fire
she'd be like damn still fine as she
burnt
but what i'm saying is this dude she uh
she um
invited me to a dance or something one
time and i got my hands on her was
making out dude and i'm reaching for the
undies and she didn't even stop me and i
[ __ ] just froze up dude damn like i
had leprosy or something damn when
you're a young man it's tough man to
make that joke god make that jump yeah
because
if they deny you it's so embarrassing
when you go for a gift they go whoa whoa
whoa whoa
i want to die i had an acting teacher i
had a knife teacher who who said jeffrey
chamber was like if you want the crew
you want that part go get it if you want
that car go get it if you want that
person and you're attracting them go and
get them so i'm like [ __ ] a and
there's this girl i thought was had such
a crush on and she was a waitress and
she used to [ __ ] wait on me every day
at breakfast and i was like i'm going to
get her to go get her i'm going to go
get her and i go we should go out she
goes and she's talking always and i
think we should go out sometime and she
goes
she goes i should get back to my station
by the way i know what it is he has the
headphones on backwards oh
they hurt
they've been hurting me the whole time
so much better
so much betterly better
that's better dude [ __ ] ear was
hitting hurting me yeah you look you
look like one of those like like a star
wars star fighters you know this is gold
leader gold leader you know what i mean
for some reason they all the oranges
gold leaders they're always fat guys
they look like george lucas yeah i don't
know why they're spider pilots yeah i
agree cold
even as a kid i want to know what's so
out of shape
it can't even fit in the all right we
got one more bitched out story
what up cats so my story is
i was about 16 and i was party hopping
with my friends for about 18 19 and we
ended up at this party with like some
grown-ass men and women like
late 20s early 30s
and midway through they started like
showing off their guns and one now which
kind of threw me off you know made me a
little like timid
and then uh we started playing a beer
pong game which lasted like way too long
yeah well if i see guns you don't have
to start if if you're showing your guns
i'm getting the [ __ ] out of there yeah
man if you're just like hey look at my
gun no look at my gun see ya yeah so let
me get this straight she obviously
fizzed out for their technical issues we
had yeah we had a fellow that blew his
own face out
when i put a gun
is that right and deceased and deceased
well sometimes you like you have these
like moments of like you don't even
realize what happened till it later
cause i remember i was working at a
school you know i was like the pe person
you know and saw like the kids after
school don't say pe person say you're a
pe teacher please eric we're trying to
be honest today so the person
a car pulls up onto the school yard you
know and it's like a bunch of like
whatever kind of dudes and it's just say
it i've said it before
they were gangsters okay and then the
guy looks at me and he shows me his gun
you know and i go i just i don't know
why i did this like this but i was like
come on man
yeah it's like what are you doing
man look at these kids here dude you
know and then they got you know what to
his credit he was like you're right
you're right you know what i mean and
they pulled off i'm at a school man but
then after that i was like
it was later i was like this could have
went completely different super salary
super stock
because if people were like this like
what say what but it wasn't even i don't
know
i at least had the common sense to be
like i'm not trying to antagonize this
guy i'm just trying to appeal to his
life is this the right time yeah maybe
he's just on the right frame of mind so
you doing that he's like oh [ __ ] you're
right all right uh but it's just like
yeah you know you just have moments
right
dude it's like if i would have reacted
like you know like on a podcast reaction
where you're supposed to be hyper or
whatever i'd be dead
yeah
you know
you're lucky to run into young chin in
his game oh i know you're the [ __ ]
killer
unless i ran into chin i'd be okay yeah
yeah
no it's his gang it's not like i'm not a
gang member i was never a gang member no
one's buying it it's the people around
me yeah no one's buying that dude
there's there's chin baby good to hear
your channel
everybody in the nazi party said later
yeah
i wasn't i was just around i was just
around
i was doing paperwork yeah
what else you got nick let's finish this
guy's story got our technical
difficulties fixed
and then uh we started playing a beer
pong game which lasted like way too long
and uh they wanted a roshambo to win it
uh you take a punch i take a punch
whoever gets knocked out first wins
jesus completely bitched out
they didn't [ __ ] we left right after
that that's called smart uh
that was that was it dude
that's not getting stockton nationally
that's not the stockton national anthem
that guy just sang
[Laughter]
i just don't i don't that's not a good
example that's not a [ __ ] that's just
you going like making a common sense i'm
trying some streets that's called
intelligence yeah yeah don't be too hard
on yourself for not knocking something
that's like that's like the guy's like
you wanna hit you in the balls you hit
me in the balls okay you always be
covered up oh [ __ ] off exhausted not
hanging out with you
no thanks
yeah i hope that guy's okay
yeah i hope he don't beat himself up
over that that's not a [ __ ] out that's
like those
apparently none of these guys sent in
[ __ ] outs and we all just admitted that
we were [ __ ]
apparently there's four [ __ ] here
yeah cause that guy these ones were like
i didn't kiss a girl yeah yeah good hair
this is like if chin were cute
[Laughter]
hey what's up guys i got a king of
stinging for you
um each race being able to use their own
racial slur all right for example of me
using the term [ __ ] now i'm japanese or
at least i think so i'm pretty sure i'm
japanese i mean okay he's gonna argue
that right so it's like me saying hey yo
what up chap
or um
chappelle or derrick you know either
using the hard er or the a it's totally
up to them their preference uh maybe you
guys using the term cracker or cracker
totally up to you but that's my king
interesting it let me know if that's
okay you know um ra each race using
their own racial slur all right thanks
guys gang gang chigga
it's a legit question man
my thing is white people we don't really
have a yeah because we don't like kids
they're all cute
i guess our work is packing wood pecker
wood was a good one
first of all shout out alan jovan right
there for sending this question
i've loved his fighting graves now
working as a commentator at ufc yeah and
uh good to see him uh how do you feel
eric with with participation
you know
it's all it's all they're like you know
you know when people say this we should
remove this word that kind of thing it's
like it depends on like the word's so
polarizing when you're talking about say
the n word for instance it's like
n word either one it's polar double r
too some people do double r at the end
so then it becomes like this thing where
it's like you know
it's never going to go away
you know it's never going to go away so
it's like especially the the a whoever
gives it weight gives it but it kind of
has gone away for the most part no way
i'm saying i'm saying it's never been
more privileged
yeah this is like he's that's his matt
damon confession right there guys i'm
not using the m word anymore you know
you don't it used to be you could say
the word within context now you now it's
like you say the one word yeah but as
far as the other version with the ending
in the a you mean with other black
people talking but in wraps that's
different it's used more so today than
anytime ever before it's like part of
the culture definitely yeah i know but i
got like it's just weird it's like it's
all i think it all depends on your own
personal experience so the older you are
the more it's going to mean more to you
that it's going to be you're going to be
upset because you know the weight of the
weight of the word the young kids come
up in their favor they don't know what
says it so like oh this is just they
don't know anything that's true that's
what i'm saying lingo you have to ask
yourself like well like what do we want
to teach people do we want to
continuously teach people about the past
and how how bad things were or do we
want to like move forward so it just
depends on and i'm not saying either one
is right or wrong because there are two
schools of thought do you what in asian
community you guys ever call each other
anything like that no just think about
that too because i don't know any
japanese person that calls a japanese
friend's job i don't call my korean
friends gooks no it just doesn't come up
that was all that was all that was
awesome that was also imposed on those
groups by yeah that's not in your
culture like that's white people putting
on but that same with the black culture
like white people put that on them yeah
it kept changing for so long it was like
negro
colored you know now you know
african-american it's like it's like
that it keeps changing
uh but that one word never never changes
it's just the weight of it is going to
change but again there's people out
there who have lived in a different
experience i mean you know i'm i'm upper
middle class i i i i was like ghetto
adjacent when i grew up and so you know
i exp when i experienced racism when i
was a kid i remember i was going to the
bear my mom sent me to the beverly hills
ymca she always wanted me to have like a
different experience you know nobody's
athletic there oh yeah yeah
basketball games you got you're black
and what else um i don't even know dude
it's such a mix but okay
jewish are you jewish
it could be who knows okay
so the uh no pun intended yeah so you
like i remember this kid walks up to me
and i was on the swim team at the ymca
and he was like you know you're dirty
you're you're skin you're dirty and you
know he was being racist right but my i
would never forget it because i was like
oh
it was finally happening like i was like
having a moment when i was like oh this
is it okay you don't like me because i'm
different from you and i was like oh
okay this is what this feels like you
know what i mean but it wasn't like you
know it wasn't like how it was say a
hundred years ago when you know no you
know what i mean so it was like it's
just it's just a different like
i don't when people are still racist now
i just i just go really like like
so ignorant yeah say what do you think
like what are you doing who's this guy
i don't know yeah you're right
he went to the barber and said i think
he did
well
the melbourne mud flap from down under
back with a king it'll sting it for all
you mad dogs in the states
penal colonies
sending all your petty thieving scumbag
criminals to the other side of the world
yeah for minor crimes yeah to establish
a nice colony so 200 years later you can
use this to fight in all your wars
you're welcome
i gotta king that [ __ ] because it turned
out pretty well for us i can't hear what
you boys think penal colonies convicts
king it will sting
that question i'll take this brother
you're doing great you guys are doing
great i've been to australia i wish i
didn't have to leave i got expedited for
or whatever and i wish i didn't have to
leave man you guys have the beaches
beautiful babes cool stuff
um no rules just right yep you're doing
it good everybody's doing good you're
playing football with a mis-shaped ball
you guys are [ __ ]
you're living well
i think the mistake here is somebody
didn't go check australia out first
agree you know it'd be like it would be
like it's like i'm gonna put a legendary
house arrest and it's in like some
mansion and then you're in the mansion
like actually this is pretty nice i'm
gonna stay here terrible
blue water hot [ __ ] everywhere
australia is a beautiful like beautiful
that's like wonderful
this is the best place on earth yeah
europe sucks
yeah you guys won australia you guys won
yeah you guys won the weather you know
what i mean king in it
okay hang it
all right we'll do one more send the
thieves to the beach
i don't remember if we kinked it guys
how many people had to get stung by
jellyfish though and
eaten by great whites and crocs and
stunt bitting my snakes before they
figured it out like it is beautiful
though there's a lot of people it's not
really that way you talked to him in
australia like dude would you quit that
narrative yeah it was like no dude i was
like jumping across [ __ ]
crocodiles was on location with a buddy
and he pulls out a hamburger we just
we're walking down the street with a
hamburger and
a birds
those seagulls those seagulls have balls
out there
yeah they're both with no thought at all
just came right down and attacked for
the for the food i was like no it's not
like sydney's full of crocodiles no
all right they got those wolf bats
though rise up lights
now i'm like melt more melbourne and
sydney
dude if you say rise up lights have you
heard that
no no say rise up lights rise up lights
and that's how you say razor blades in
australian it's like the perfect wave
frozen blinds
raise up lights riser lights
rise up lights rise up lights rise
surprises
rising lights rise up lights
right there blades rise above it
i can't i can't
i can't i know i'm throwing an accent on
it yeah right
all right last one let's see it what's
up brandon what's up theo it's alex here
from virginia
virginia just to be clear we don't have
people
riding their horses in their white bed
sheets or anything like that so don't
get too excited theo
got a little king or sing it for you
though
chickens in the backyard
good thing is get fresh eggs out back
whenever you want them my girl thinks
they're cute
some of the best fertilizer you can ever
get it's chicken [ __ ] you got in the
composter right there for next year's
garden nice little setup but uh kind of
a pain in the ass you know a nice
creature like this when you're hungover
out here making noise carrying on until
you feed them
but you know you get the fresh organic
eggs every morning for breakfast massive
ones too
i feel bad for these girls popping these
out every morning their undercarriage is
all torn up
oh yeah man king here sing it these yard
birds out back
that dog
and i love the fact that he takes into
the you know if you even to lay in bed
and imagine a chicken birthing a huge
egg that you're gonna go griddle up that
[ __ ] is really
barbie that's really the ultimate
slavery really that's barbaric delicious
that's barbaric barbaric delicious kids
yeah i probably sting it man those
chickens are loud they [ __ ] everywhere i
don't like their dinosaur feet
they're beautiful you remember
he was like killing coyotes and [ __ ] to
keep him away from the chicken coop yeah
he had a whole coupe exhausting a whole
coop situation you get a friendly
chicken though man there's nothing more
nice than sitting back with a friendly
chicken and just hugging
you know what i don't like
watching these videos where you see like
cows and chickens acting like dog like
dogs
or they're acting like pets because they
imprinted on they they're going to try
it in our minds that like oh these are
just dumb animals that they don't have
no feelings or nothing i have to believe
that when i'm sitting at ocean pride
yeah me too
i mean lions lions get super attached to
you it's weird because they're like dogs
they're social animals and you become
part of their pride
people are owned look at that yeah how
old are the lions it's cute to me
lions lions will literally get attached
to you like you but how old are they i
don't know i mean they probably live
what they're probably young though if
they're 18 years old this is what i'm
saying you see this kind of stuff and
you go oh god i can't go to outback
steakhouse yeah i can't eat a flamingo
you know what i mean yeah i know what
you mean but also i stopped drinking but
also kill him look at that look at that
little guy they look cool
they're cute that guy's got ulterior
motives i've seen this kind of stuff
before yeah look at that
there's theo's moves right here i think
it's cute time's up same name
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
they're cute as [ __ ] they are yeah it
looks like a [ __ ] paradise i couldn't
eat cows if they were my friends like
that no you still eat these though yeah
you just don't die naturally i love
steak oh [ __ ] look at that [ __ ]
horns dude oh god is that acting like a
puppy that's a [ __ ] bull
well if your pit bull had freaking horns
on it you it wouldn't be a pet anymore
yeah yeah yeah like freaking house cats
are
62 pounds away from like running your
house yeah that's right savage you know
what i mean yeah you know what's going
on videos but cats be slapping people
the most efficient killers in all the
lights yeah
and here's the thing people don't
remember you die in your house when you
got cats in there they eat you buddy
boom
happens all the time senior lady dies
something happens
lightning
skillet falls off a shelf hits her yep
cat's eater yep i don't know if that's
all the time that's true is it people
should be keeping these skillets in an
area that can they can fall they're
heavy
dude we're talking seniors bob
wow
some guys consume the head neck and arm
of their dead owner
they don't care about you
they don't care about you i'm sorry
yes your pets will eat you when you die
a bit sooner or
go for the neck face later expose the
areas first
but yeah i don't think rogan dies man i
think he
yeah i think he lives there he's going
to have all of us yeah yeah i don't know
i got to call him i haven't talked to
him in a while no no it's been a while
we always get it nick that's it
all right
all right kiss laugh boston
and then
the dallas next weekend denver for me
this weekend then i got chicago improv
chamber schomburg prop plavlov
[Music]
guys it's only like 40 minutes outside
chicago in traffic you only have two
hours i will be staying at in in chicago
it's like saying santa barbara is l.a
right same [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah um san
antonio this saturday one giant show
saturday bud light courtyard event
center that's san antonio this saturday
then next week i'm in denver mama i'm
coming home tommy works downtown
thursday friday saturday
can't wait yeah mr theovan what do you
got doug that's gonna be sick i'm gonna
be in charlotte and durham this weekend
and then next weekend i'm going to be in
chattanooga and knoxville
so home huh those are excited about that
excited about that man good to see you
guys today too man good to see you
brian countless bro one of the top 60 or
70 men out there probably thank you also
go go see stevie i hate when he does
that
stevie's at moon tower comedy festival
doing scissor bros with jeremiah go see
him this week look it up he's in austin
this guy's brought me up like this
before this is the top 357
men i've met in my life you know like
[ __ ] i got 60. so that means you know
i'm 357 because if you're saying
i mean if i'm in the top 357 yeah i'm
357.00
[Music]
the paint i do not think i am in flow
black rifle coffee i'm ready to go i
need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn hungry like i'm fresh off keto
seeing red like andrew santino every
song i hit like the great bambino
burning ain't the queso and the
quesoritos but everything's gonna be
fine
hate on me i do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times they sliding into my dms a
couple of you tripping couldn't beat him
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz meaning
y'all edible just got my eyebrows
threaded and i'm feeling incredible
brendan's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
[Music]
oh yeah king and a sting beast
[Music]
on a string
[Music]
you